good evening everyone I'm Carla Cohen
I'm one of the owners of politics and
prose and I want to welcome you here
tonight we're extremely happy to have
Martin Maher here probably the the most
recognizable name in the as a writer of
about economics in the United States the
history of banking he has this book
seemed to be waiting for him to write it
a book that questions the position of
the Fed in the in the in that we've had
two books this year that were about Alan
Greenspan and the the effect that he's
had on the economy through his position
as the head of the federal banking
system Martin Maher takes it takes us
much further along by showing us the the
and asking us questions about where we
want the Fed to go and where we want our
economy to go in the next few decades so
it's with great pleasure that I
introduce Martin Maher thank you this is
a this is a tremendously lucky book it
was it was finished August first all the
editing done everything ready to go
last August first and it should have
been published February or so and with
have been published in February people
would have sort of scratched their heads
and wondered what it was all about and
what was he talking about and it didn't
fit into the ethos
despite the 1991 experience when Alan
Greenspan testified several times before
the Congress complaining that there
seemed to be a 50 mile an hour headwind
that was that was preventing the economy
from reacting to what the Fed was doing
despite the collapse and it really is a
collapse of all of the theoretical
models of what central banks do in the
economy despite the shrinking importance
of the banks themselves which are what a
central bank relates to despite the
clearly faulty assumptions that were
underlying all of the descriptions of
the transmissions mechanisms by which
central banks and monetary policy are
supposed to influence what goes on in
the real economy nevertheless it was all
but universally assumed that monetary
policy would control the course of the
economy the great statement of it and it
may you know may have a historical value
was Paul Krugman's in the New York Times
when he said that when the economy turns
down everybody knows what the
prescription is you lower interest rates
and call me in six months and that you
know we're now at six months it's not
getting better
it's probably still getting a little
worse where you had a where in previous
slowdowns where you have basically a
monetary cause then you could buy
monetary means to solve the problem and
of course in October of 98 which is
where my book begins you had a collapse
of belief in the in the financial
mechanisms world worldwide there if you
could reassert confidence confidence
would do it and the economy would come
back here there is a greater problem as
there was in 1991 in 1991 there had been
a great real estate boom people had made
plans of themselves over real estate
banks had made plans of themselves
lending to real estate projects that
were never gonna pay out and there was a
real problem until some of that worked
through there was a limit to what you
could achieve by monetary policy this
year we are looking at the debt treatise
of the of the telecom situation where
you know the last estimates that have
been made of the five percent of the
fiber-optic cable that has been laid is
actually being used and it's going to be
some time before we get into double
digits
so we had these immense investments that
were made which are going to be losers
and they're gonna be losses to an
extraordinary degree many of them a
normal bankruptcy the lenders get 40 50
60 70 80 percent with the telecom
situation if you get 15 you're lucky so
that we have a real problem and the
notion that you can solve it by having
the chairman of the Fed kiss it and make
it well has not struck me as something
that was that that was particularly
logical but if I when I said that in
August of last year it didn't I I did a
work-in-progress seminar my colleagues
at the Brookings Institution in this in
the spring of 2000 and some very
distinguished people came I was very
flattered by it and the point that I was
making I was trying to get their
guidance into what it all meant to them
because I was looking at it and I
thought it was important but I wasn't
sure what it what it meant that we were
moving from a from a Bank mediated
financial world to a market mediated
financial world and the information
systems of banks and markets are
extremely different banks if they're
working well and my old friend John
Hyman who was control of the currency
says that the error in this analysis is
that it assumes the banks knew what they
were doing which was a strong assumption
but if if things are and you know when
when when the Asian crisis hit Treasury
secretary Rubin gave a talk in this town
saying that that they went to the banks
to find out more about what was
happening in Korea and they found out
banks didn't know anything about what
was happening in in in Korea
nevertheless certainly in theory and
often enough in practice and there's
still enough old-time lending offices
around the information systems of banks
are narrow but they're deep you look at
companies you know what companies are
doing you've been you've been through a
great deal of judgment process with your
borrowers you know what their business
is you've studied their business plan
you've kept an eye on it you've had
somebody going through the files and you
know going in and getting his shoes to
and looking at what's going on but what
you know is that business and with luck
something about that industry markets
are broad and shallow the information
system of markets is very short term and
and looks does not try to understand
what the business is - anything like the
same extent we've having these great
examples now of people who were
supposedly distinguished analysts of
various high tech institutions who which
was which was selling stock through the
company that the analysts worked for and
it turns out that what they understood
about the business was limited but in
general markets cover of a wide range of
experience there a wide range of people
looking at it
some people know something about what
they're buying some people don't but the
whole system is subject to to wave
motions in part because it is shallow
but it is also brought the question of
how these two information systems are
going to interact in a world where we
still have banks as important
institutions but the decisions are made
increasingly by markets and what is the
position of a central bank working in a
in a in a world where the institutions
that it is designed to influence the
banks are less and less important and
this outside world of markets which are
not controlled in any significant way by
the central bank has become the major
factor well I had my work in progress
seminar with my Brookings colleagues and
at the end of it there was general
agreement that I was putting too much
weight on this that there was doubtless
there was some truth to it but that's
not what was happening and so I went
back and thought about it some more and
I thought god damn it that is what's
happening and what I'm I'm dealing with
is accumulated habits of mind and you
have seen them over the course of these
six six months that doesn't mean that
it's it's it's easy to understand you
know a Greenspan looked at this problem
himself in the fall
99 I guess and he sees good news you
know he brings certain elements of good
news to the world he's basically a
follower of live Nets think slit all is
for the best in the best of all possible
world rational expectations leads you
there I mean if if the market is higher
than you think it ought to be it means
that people know more than YouTube and
and therefore the you get certain
self-reinforcing trends and while
greenspan is a very careful observer and
analyst of the information that comes in
nevertheless his instinct is whatever is
happening is for the best the right
people are in charge the right things
are happening the productivity is going
up and he specifically talked about this
business of the markets and the banks
and it says means the central bank has
two strings to its bow if the banks
aren't working right and go to the
market if the markets aren't working
right well that's nonsense but he had to
believe that there's a need for an
equilibrium position here and that was
his in the fall of 98 it's not so these
are two very different games they're not
going to work neatly two together and
indeed they don't for anyway this book
which got finished in august and would
have no might not have sunk like a stone
but would live but the waves would have
obscured a lot of it had to be postponed
for the reasons of mexico and gave you
which is that the Free Press which
publishes it is owned by Simon &
Schuster and Simon & Schuster
unbeknownst by the way to the people who
play your Free Press had a contract with
Bob Woodward to do a book about
Greenspan which in fact didn't get
finished until October but God brought
out one month after he finished writing
him um and they did not want to have
something else on their list that might
be competitive to which so we got put
off all the way to June I think it is
fair to say I was pissed but it turned
out to be an extremely lucky event
because the book has had a lot more
attention and sold but not to be
mercenary a lot more copies than it
would have if it had come out four five
six months sooner
the its it's now become obvious that
what works with a highly leveraged
banking system where a central bank can
control the money supply is not going to
be anywhere near as powerful in its
impact on the economy when technology
has made all financial institutions
congruent when people can monetize most
of their assets by writing checks
against the equity in their homes or
against the margin in their securities
account and when interest rates beyond
the very shortest I set not by the banks
but in the markets when when years ago
there was a prime rate and everything
was hooked to the prime rate and
everything
supposedly there were there were rules
of thumb they told you how different
loans should should be at different
maturities from the bank's prime rate
and there was a bank this I remember
whose bag called st. Louis and
southwestern that would get itself some
publicity every few months by announcing
that it was changing its prime rate at a
time when people knew other banks were
gonna do that too and at that point the
Fed which can indeed control short-term
interest rates completely was a very
powerful secret society there's a great
story that isn't in the book but that I
used in I don't know why it wasn't Italy
in the book I used in my Wall Street
Journal piece of a few weeks ago great
true story from the memoirs of Sherman
Maysles professor of economics at the
University of California and was a
governor of the Fed back in the late 60s
and early years seventy and it's the
story of the time that Nixon swore in
Arthur burns to succeed Bill Martin who
had been chairman of the Fed for 19
years and Burns was coming in to be
chairman and Nixon invited the governors
of the Fed to the Oval Office to be
present at Burns's swearing-in and they
came and Nixon was in one of his jovial
moods and said that how he hoped that
Burns would lower interest rates make it
cheaper for the government
to borrow ease conditions in the economy
that the Bill Martin had been awfully
tough on the economy which indeed in the
last years of the of the Johnson
administration he did because he was
trying to prevent the inflationary
impact of the Vietnam War and that he
hoped Burns would would would take it
easier on the government and Maslin his
memoirs said that it was extremely
embarrassing for the governors of the
Fed who were present at this occasion
because they had indeed voted a week
before to lower interest rates and to
ease monetary conditions and nobody knew
the President of the United States
didn't know that the Federal Reserve
Board had voted to lower interest rates
a week before for big banks the big
investment banks hired what were called
fed watchers to study the markets to
determine whether the motions in the
markets were related to a change in
policy in the Fed because nobody knew
six months later they would in some
vague way let you know that the Federal
Open Market Committee had said this or
that vague change in the instructions to
the desk that actually did the buying
and selling in New York but you never
really knew what they had done and
certainly you didn't know while they
were they were doing it the the banks
were the key financial intermediaries in
Bill Martin's time in the 50s and 60s in
the years after World War two when banks
port portfolios were full of government
bonds and you could change the price
market price of the government bonds by
moving interest rates quarter of a year
percentage point throughout that that
period what was done was that the Fed
took an action that influenced what the
banks did what the banks did influenced
what happened in the real economy the
market caught up with the real economy
somewhat later the market moved last but
all of this was started in this
secretive way at the Fed today you know
they come out in center stage at 2:15 in
the afternoon and if they're going to do
it between meetings greens
we'll probably time it to have something
to do with options exploration date so
he can leverage the speculative efforts
of market players in in in his way and
it's it's now a very theatrical
enterprise it was a secretive enterprise
and it is now a theatrical enterprise
now the notion that this does not change
the situation
I can accept almost anything I can all
be wrong I've known to be wrong a lot
myself but the notion that these two
institutions the one of which was
completely secret so that the President
of the United States didn't know that
they changed interest rates and the
other one which somebody comes out at
2:15 in the afternoon and makes an
announcement these are very different
institutions and one of the oddities is
that not only the outside world has
failed to recognize this the Fed has
failed to recognize it it is it is it is
still it is a staff driven bureaucratic
institution that tends to duplicate what
it did before and that pays some
attention to the Chairman but not much
to other governor when Janet Yellen was
a governor of the FET used to say it was
a wonderful job if you wanted to go
around the country and make speeches
written by the staff otherwise if that's
not what you wanted to wasn't so so so
great one of the interesting aspects of
this story is that the event that sort
of gave the Fed its charter to move
independently in 1951 the famous Accord
not so famously an accord between the
Fed and the true and léa Treasury has
virtually dropped out of the history
books my my kids have gone through good
high school history course in which they
used college textbooks and I've read
through the ties no mention of the of a
court there are there are two very good
biographies of harry truman that i've
read neither of the mentions of the the
accord but this is the charter not only
for the independence of the Fed but
really it is the Charter for the
independence of all the central banks
around the world which have now been
given much greater independence and my
favorite story in this book
would really paint it's obviously been
in print because I got it somewhere but
it was in print in the privately printed
memoirs of Alan's brow is they is the
story of the day that that that the
fight really blew up between the
Treasury and the Fed you're talking
about the early days of the Korean War
the government wants to finance the
Korean War on the cheap the way it
financed World War two on the cheap but
wants to set maximum interest rate of
two and a half percent for 20-year paper
and pay three quarters of one percent
for one year paper the Federal Reserve
is looking at an inflation rate of which
is approaching six percent and saying
you know if you let the government
borrow at these rates then we're going
to have an enormous inflationary
pressure we have to do something about
it and John Schneider was then Secretary
of the Treasury he made a public speech
saying that because of the government's
monetary needs was going to have to be a
law issue of paper and it would be your
marketed quote within the pattern of the
rates which was three quarters of one
percent to two and a half percent and
Marriner Eccles was then vice chairman
of the Fed having been chairman and he
let it be known he didn't think much of
this and Alan Sproul was president fell
Reserve Bank of New York and he made a
public speech letting it know that the
Fed was thought that the fellows are
back in New York thought this was very
unwise and Truman summoned the Board of
Governors to the White House the only
time so if I could find out in my
research that the Board of Governors was
ever ordered to come to the White House
to meet with the President and they did
and Truman said no he said when I was a
soldier and last war and World War one I
put all of my money into Liberty buttons
and when I came back after the war to I
wanted to stand I was gonna start my
haberdashery
I had to sell the Liberty Bonds to stock
the haberdashery and I got 90 cents on
the dollar but I don't want that to
happen to today's GI and you know you
have here at issue nobody can argue with
that the the understanding of what these
interest rate
changes can mean to ordinary people is
something that you can lose sight of
very easily if you're a governor of the
Fed nevertheless they have a
responsibility to maintain the value of
the currency so at the end of this you
know they went back to their meeting and
they said that's it that's it one can
see why the president feels that way but
we have an obligation to see to it even
if it means the government has to pay
more when it wants to borrow money to
make to make sure that the value of the
currency service survives and from this
battle came the Accord signed in March
of 1951 so I tried to get somebody
interested in doing an op-ed piece for
the 50th anniversary of the Accord but
it's too obscure which is very strange
it is it is one of the if you're going
to make a list of ten leading events in
the economy of the 20th century this
would have to be one of them but it's
been it's been gone you know these these
things affect people in ways my own
contact with this sort of thing is in
the exchange rate question I wrote the
Centennial history of the Metropolitan
Opera I wear a different hat as a music
critic and it's it's a it's a gorgeous
book I have nothing to do with its being
a gorgeous book the iconography was by
Gerry Fitzgerald and it was put out for
was put out for bids to printing
companies around the world and the
winner was dine upon in Japan and they
did a gorgeous job it is really a very
beautiful book and they were if they
could do it at a price which made it
possible to sell the book in 1983 for
$35 and the yen was then at 280 that was
when the contract was signed the books
were printed they were shipped by slow
Freight to Philadelphia they were
unloaded in a warehouse and they were
sold they were all sold I'm pleased to
say in about two months and they went
back to dine upon and said we need some
more books but the yen was then at 160
and in order and and and the dine upon
would have to charge 60% more per copy
to the Metropolitan Opera Guild and to
Simon and intrested which had jointly
published it so we've never been a
and and dine upon will not permit its
place to be used by any other publishing
house by any other reprinted so this
book has never never been possible to do
a reissue of this book because of the
movements of exchange rates with very
abstruse question but it does indeed
impact on people flood the key date and
in some ways is probably the 1987 crash
because the Fed then found itself the
lender of last resort not to the banks
because the banks were not the important
phenomena I mean the the market dropped
twenty point eight percent in one day
the futures market dropped twenty eight
percent in one day this had never
happened before it hasn't happened since
let's hope it never happens again
but there was obviously a crisis and
there was panic and the Fed poured money
out into the banks the only place where
the Fed could pour the money was by it
was by buying a great deal of Treasury
paper pumping cash in the banks and the
banks clutched it to their bosom because
they were at least as panicked as
everybody else and the guy who really
made it possible for a recovery to
happen on on a very rapid time scale was
Gerry Corrigan who was then president
New York's Fed big tough Mick went
around to all of these soft bankers and
and and really in a very threatening way
said to them the money was not being
supplied to them for their use it was
being supplied for the market the
specialist the Bankers Trust was the
largest lender to the specialist
community in the New York Stock Exchange
it had a portfolio insurance program
that was selling stock to the
specialists who couldn't buy it because
they didn't have any money because
Bankers Trust wouldn't lend them the
year money you know where all of this
nonsense was was was going onto its car
can put us put a stop um but at that
moment with the FDIC out there to
protect depositors with the Federal
Reserve both in the theory of central
banking going back to Badgett and in a
law forbidden to lend money to in
solvent banks
so that there was a limit to how deep it
could it could reach in advancing money
but the FDIC was taking care of the
depositors in the insolvent banks but
theory went backwards
the FDIC became a lender of last resort
to the banks as we could see in the 80s
they didn't do a very good job of it um
and then for Federal Home Loan Bank
board of of course also with the SNL's
and the Fed in effect became the lender
of last resort to the market it's a
problem and it's an opportunity there is
a concept in economics which is stolen
from the insurance industry which my
friends at Brookings didn't believe
called a moral hazard it's Robert Robert
Solow first brought it up and what moral
hazard means is that if you insure a
house for more than it's worth someone
will burn it down and and this and so we
have a year situation where there are a
lot of people in the market who believe
in what they call the Greenspan put it
doesn't matter how dumb you are or how
much money you're gonna lose you will be
protected at the end because the Federal
Reserve will come around and buy it the
the the Fed is is desperately anxious
not to have people believe this but we
have long-term capital and long-term
capital was a classic case of you know
of the Fed being being willing to put
itself in a very bad position in order
to protect people because they didn't
know how well I I say in the book is
what they what they had learned is that
they didn't know what the banks had been
doing with long-term capital that their
own supervisory procedures had been
negligent and therefore they were
terrified that if this crowd went under
and you had a lot of investigations by
courts and by you Congress the Fed would
look very bad I think that was in fact
the basic reason for doing it but
certainly everybody else who was in the
hedge fund business looked at this and
said it doesn't matter what we do we get
in deep trouble they'll come bail us out
and this is a problem what's happened
this this year in my analysis of these
things you know we now have
I have to come back full circle the
question of what is the mediating device
for monetary policy when we had a gold
standard and Karl Marx was active in
England and studying what had happened
in the 1850s he said that what mean that
the way the Bank of England maintained
the gold standard main main maintained
its own possession of gold is that when
there was a drain of gold the Bank of
England raised interest rates are enough
to lower the price of paper of consoles
in the British market so that the French
would come in and buy it and when the
price got low enough the gold would flow
back in when the when they said that 7%
would draw gold from the moon it wasn't
the 7% that was doing it it was the
reduction in the price of the asset to
get away from Marx they're probably the
most profound student of central banking
today is Charles Goodhart
in England and he has come around in
several talks his feeling that yes what
the central bank does it's been
effective because it affects the price
of assets now if you look back you know
if you look at Sydney Homer's books
about interest rates one of the things
that that Homer insisted that people
learn is that it wasn't the stock market
that mattered it was the bond market it
was the it was the fixed yield stuff and
the price of that and quite clearly if
the Fed changes the price of interest
rates it changes the price of Li of the
fixed yield instruments and now we have
moved to a time when the fixed yield is
considerably less important by
comparison to the equity pieces and the
Fed finds itself willy-nilly taken and
it's definitely nilly nobody will admit
that they take an interest in the stock
market but finds itself with a need to
mediate somehow not only the bond market
the fixed income market but also the
stock market if you look at what
greenspan has been doing this year it
seems to me that what makes sense is
that he has been trying to avoid a
situation where the market fully
reflects the decline in earnings and
especially the decline in earnings
expectations so that
the we aren't talking about the Nasdaq
bubble which means there were people who
think this was a great tragedy up to a
point it was but if you know if children
didn't feel heat when they touched the
stove we'd have Lawton with three
fingered children around and and they
have to have some sort of learning
process you get something like the
Nasdaq market in early 2000 but the the
market as a whole really has not done
all that badly and now you look at a
world where because of the influence of
the central bank there are fewer
bargains than there might have been
otherwise and what this is going to mean
on the way back we will we will all find
out I sympathize basically with with
with grains brands position I am old
enough to have to have studied with the
Joseph Schumpeter who did not really
talk much about creative destruction
what he did talk about was investment
opportunities and the extent to which
the long waves in economies were
controlled by investment opportunities
which grew mostly in the 20th century
out of technological change and I still
believe that what has happened in the
information heck technology world is a
is a Schumpeterian revolution that
there's a long long time ahead of us of
heavy investment and I am enough of a
Keynesian to believe that it is the
investment piece that governs what's
what what's going to happen I like to
make a joke a little joke that if the
Fed was really really wanted to help us
these days it would it would stop it's
unrelenting opposition to electronic
payments because one of the things that
has slowed down the move in information
technology is that guys can automate
their accounts payable they can automate
their accounts receivable but they can't
put the payment piece in place because
the Fed is protecting the jobs of the
people who work for the Fed and process
the checks and the Fed has made it
extremely difficult for us to move along
the path of electronic payments it is it
is not a major part of what's going
wrong but it would be nice if we could
move it forward the feds reaction to
this
had a review of my book by Bob McTeer
who was present Federal Reserve Bank of
Dallas in the financial times who said
that this was the silliest thing in the
book because the reason we haven't had
electronic payments is that people don't
want it and the Fed being conscious of
what people want and don't want
therefore was not providing it on that
note I think anybody who has any
comments or questions that's what I'm
here for yes and one thing that bothers
me is I don't see the logic of that the
bank is saving money when the prime rate
is lowered isn't it correct that they're
paying less when they have to borrow
money they're paying you less money by
the lowering of the rate why can't they
pass a portion of that savings to me the
depositor will at least don't change my
rate instead of lowering my passing on
any of their savings they allow my rate
it makes no sense at all they don't
their savings come from the fact that
they can borrow money more cheaply when
you buy a CD you are lending money to
the banks can you please stand out okay
the question was why do the banks lower
lower the rates and your CDs are on your
money market fund when the Fed lowers
the rates and the answer is because
that's that that's what they can do I
have everybody is gonna be doing it the
Fed controls the short-term rate and you
know the banks do do do well when rates
go down that's the sort of basic
statement is that bank liabilities
reprice before bank assets read price
that is banks have loans that are six
months a year two years longer than that
and those are if there are a fixed price
that stays but they can turn on a dime
on what they pay when they borrow money
because they can't do it as you say why
don't they do it when the Fed doesn't
what doesn't make sense is that they
don't lower the rate on your credit card
yeah
that that when they can get money
cheaper they don't lower the price they
charge for money they lower the prime
rate but fewer guys get the prime rate
the problem you know the banks mostly
don't want to do what they call spread
banking anymore anyway they want they're
they're most likely to sell their loans
but they have to borrow money in order
to lend money and when they borrow money
they will borrow as cheaply as they can
when the when the Fed puts more money
into the system which is basically what
the Open Market Committee does when it's
lowering rates then the price of that
money is going to get down it's gonna
end and the bank that pays more is going
to be deluge with money and find they
don't have any profitable use for it so
they're gonna lower rates too they just
will yes Bob Feinberg
without asking a leading question in the
87 89 period when the banking system was
being bailed out doesn't follow on what
you're saying that
defend drugs interest rates now at
effective the price
that's not like they don't they we're
trying to raise the price of assets they
saw that they could no longer get the
rates they were used to people like this
gentleman now a bank so they took their
money two points ones they took their
money out of the banks have put it into
the stock market touching off the
irrational exuberance and the second
point is it allowed banks to build
rebuild their capital without having to
make hogs
that's something hopefully created work
well the the time the the the
interesting time period for us right now
is 97 when we had the Asian crisis 98
when the whole world almost came apart
99 when everybody was worried about y2k
on all three of these the Fed put extra
money into the system
there is certainly a case to be made I
I'm I'm I'm agnostic but there's a case
to be made that the Nasdaq bubble was
blown up by the feds actions in 97 to
try to bail out the Asian situation in
98 when everything had had had frozen on
them and then in 99 when there was a
perfectly rational fear that there was
going to be major trouble on December
31st 1999 and that you wanted to make
sure that there wouldn't be any
liquidity problems associated with that
so the money supply whatever that word
means was probably much greater in the
first three months of the year 2000 when
the Nasdaq bubble reached that
extravagant size than it would have been
without those three crises and I am NOT
it is not in me to blame the Fed on any
of those three because they had a real
problem they handled it with the only
tool they got and it may well be that
the bubble that was then created has
made the downturn worse now the the
downturn still isn't all that bad and
I'm not sure it's gonna get that again
a lot longer than people have been
thinking to get better but I'm not at
all sure that it is gonna be that bad
bad because I sense an underlying
maintenance of demand no this is very
delicate work let's just take a moment
of sympathy with the Fed you you get
these Milton Friedman theories of steady
growth of 3% but from the point of view
of the guys who are on the desk there's
a cash demand related to Christmas
there's a cash demand related people
going on vacation on the 4th of July
there are companies that have extra
money because they're about to pay out
on the Social Security taxes for their
employees the government's money in the
bank in the banking system which is
billions and billions of dollars every
day that fluctuates the Treasury's tax
and loan accounts and the guys who are
working the desk have to balance all of
these things the thing that begins every
day at the Fed is a call from the
Treasury to tell the guy who's running
the money desk how large the Treasury's
balances will be in the banking system
that day and one of the oddities to me
of the work on this book is that neither
the Treasury nor the Fed would supply
that fellow to me the guy who did it on
the Fed side was Peter Fisher who was
easy to talk to but you could not
through the Treasury said there wasn't
such a person basically but and but that
and it's a it's a purely technical and
mechanical job but it has to be done
done done well then over and above that
you lay the problems of monetary policy
so that we aren't talking about
something that there's a big argument in
economics some years ago was between
quote rules close quote and quote
discretion close quote and what the
Friedman i'ts was saying is that you
must have rules for the central bank to
follow and Volcker at one point tried to
do that and that it doesn't work because
people are variable and what people in
do tomorrow there's a there's an his a
Wall Street economist who makes a
presentation and he draws a graph and
the x-axis is time
the y-axis is the degree of human
involvement and the closer you are to
the abscissa where you have the least
time in the least human involvement the
better your mathematics is gonna be but
further out you go in other directions
the less useful your mathematics is
gonna be let me let me get other people
yes gentlemen over there if you make a
further comment about the change in the
secrecy and the operation of the of the
fed something about its Genesis was it
changing the style of the Chairman or
concerned about leaks in the media or
change in society or what's your
analysis event it's it's being forced
upon them by technology it isn't
something they like very much as a
matter of fact the Fed has requested the
Congress to increase the penalties on
people who reveal the contents of bank
examinations during this this this
period when they've been more open or in
some other ways but we are if you're
going to have a market dominated world
markets are gonna work best with more
information and greenspan is very
conscious of this and he talks a good
game on disclosure he doesn't really
feel it and the institution doesn't feel
it at all but if you're going to have a
market dominated world you're going to
have to have much more information out
there my own instinct is that the
umbrella regulation aspect of financial
institutions and once the computer was
there and you could run through all the
accounts every day if you have an
insurance company if you were a
brokerage house if you were a bank
whoever you were once the computer
opened all the accounts every day
routinely the difference between a bank
and an insurance company and brokerage
house was very greatly diminished and
when you got that when you you got that
degree of access to information that
once only banks had then you really had
to start opening it up the problem that
the Fed had was that when Bill Martin
was chairman and the banks did
two-thirds to three-quarters of all the
financial
intermediation then you could you could
keep things secret but now the banks do
20% of the financial intermediation
and they do that gracelessly you know
you have a mortgage but the bank isn't
funding the mortgage that mortgage is
out there being funded by Fannie or
Freddie or some insurance company you
have an automobile loan the bank isn't
funding that automobile well it's out as
an asset-backed security all the loans
the banks can sell into the market they
want to sell into the market so that the
role of the central bank which once went
on this this question that I was asked
about you know they lower the rates what
what is why do they lower the rates on
me all of these things which once the
banks were supposed to be able to make
the decisions they can't anymore the
market makes the decisions therefore
over time you're going to have to move
toward an SEC orientation with
regulation and access to a lot of
information and away from the banking
area where the mean the basic concern of
a bank and of a central bank is his
confidence Herman Herman Melville wrote
a great novel called the confidence man
which he was never able to finish and
one of the reasons that I don't think he
could in his own mind decide whether
this confidence man was going on a
Mississippi riverboat was really God or
was really a con man and that's that's
what you have now with the with as
they've got to get the information how
people can make up their own minds I
take too long yes gentleman over there
at the end of the day do you think what
Greenspan's been doing for the past six
months makes sense and is it gonna work
in terms of the economy enjoy the
markets it's it's work I think it's it's
done as much as it was likely to do
what's gonna work is is the growth of
investment opportunities again you know
if if the new Microsoft
if Microsoft this is half a joke but
only half if the new Microsoft program
can really be sold to the American
people is something they need and if
it's a lousy clunky program like all the
other Mike
soft programs you can't run it on the
computer your own you're gonna have to
buy a new computer to run it that'll be
a big help but there there are there are
all sorts of things coming around which
people are going to be with guys who run
businesses are going to feel they can
save a lot of money on they can exploit
for various profitable opportunities or
they will be afraid that other guys in
their business will be using it and will
disadvantage them I think that the the
innovative possibilities are still so
great with all of this equipment and
with the new programs and the and and
the improvements in the speed of the
chips and such thing that there will be
a groundswell of demand again in this
area and that's what God gets you out
what gets you out is not just that you
reduce the interest rates if in fact
you've got to stuff now and it's not
servicing its own capital costs yes
coordination around the world I mean
something like two-thirds of the dollar
are outside of the US and and you know
for all the economies are down as they
seem to be now there's no really good
place to put the money and how do you
get out of that conundrum well what what
what has happened until most of the
post-war period is that when the world
gets worried it wants dollars and that's
been happening again this year and it's
interesting because we weren't that
conscious of the worries at the
beginning of the year but quite clearly
there's been an inflow you could explain
the inflow of capital this is a country
that has a 300 billion dollar a year
trade deficit we have to have a lot of
money coming in so we can finance that
trade deficit ah one of the numbers that
I pay a lot of attention to is a number
published by the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York every Thursday which is the
quantity of Treasury paper now Treasury
paper plus federal agency paper are held
by the Federal Reserve
Bank of New York for a foreign official
account for foreign governments and
foreign central banks that's 700 billion
dollars that's a lot of money if
foreigners want dollars then that number
doesn't go up because they take their
dollars and they buy American
instruments of various source with it if
foreigners decide they don't want
dollars then that number does go up
because they take their dollars to their
own central bank they get marks euros
now francs pounds whatever with it and
by by an agreement worked out by Arthur
burns in the early seventies the foreign
governments and central banks shipped
the money back here to be invested by
the Federal Reserve Bank of New York to
date our trade deficit has been financed
by an autonomous inflow of dollars this
has its side effects in terms of the
fact that the dollar is high our exports
are expensive we can import more cheaply
and this we can this takes too long but
what will happen to it in theory this
was going to be the year of resurgent
Europe we were going to have a
moderately tough year they were gonna
have a great year it would help us as
they got as they pulled out of their
problems markets presumably equilibrate
a lot of this stuff but they don't work
because in the way they are supposed to
fairly often because there are these
immense psychological factors as part of
it I think most of us have been
surprised to see the Euro continue to
weaken against the dollar
this is not what anybody expected or
wanted but the notion that you can
control it by waving a wand I mean Jim
Baker and the plaza agreement and all of
that stuff from the 80s demonstrated
reasonably well but there's a limit to
how much you can do on that it's it's
not by the way essentially the central
banks get involved in this but the
exchange value of the currency is a
Treasury Department problem and the Fed
is a handmade
in that area always has been and I
suspect always will be one of my
favorite stories is from 1981-82 I went
to see Volker whom I've known since we
were both kids and I said you can't keep
it up that's when he had the interest
rate to 20% and he said why not I said
because it's because you're bankrupting
the third world and you're destroying
the cross rates in Europe in other words
people in Europe would not sell Pat
would not sell marks to buy towers they
sell francs to buy dollars so that the
relationship of the mark and the franc
was being very grievously affected by
what we were doing with our interest
rates which doesn't make much sense and
he said he said other people have their
problems he said we have our problems I
am hired to take care of our problems
central banks are very nationalist
institutions Treasury Department's can
be affected maybe by the foreign
minister but the central banks much less
so this doesn't answer your your
question it doesn't have an answer
presumably at some point in the game and
what hope it is when hopes it isn't
drastic and sudden and difficult to
manage it will once again come to the
attention of the people who are moving
money around the world that we have this
huge trade deficit and I should fancy
that at that point the dollar will begin
to sink but certainly hasn't happened
yet you bring Poland into the EU are as
it's not and into the East ECU as it's
now operating and we don't know anyway
yes gentlemen here bearing in mind that
the central banks Canada effective
markets directly by increasing the money
is available for investment on an
international basis could you speak to
the coordination between the
international level between central
banks ah
I think the Bank for International
Settlements is where a great deal of
this coordination among central banks
occurs
Jonnie Jonnie highness with an honorary
central bank has said that they get on
with each other very well because nobody
else likes them
on the its these are once again
nationalist institutions they're going
to look at what they assumed to be the
credit needs of their own economies
having said that we have a situation now
obviously where the European countries
have joined together in a common
currency which will exist in physical
form in January and where Latin America
has has dollarized to a degree that we
could not have expected before what this
is going to mean in note no central bank
well
Greenspan in 97 made this interesting
comment the United States could not
expect to be an island of prosperity in
a sea of depressed economies the first
time I had ever heard a chairman of the
of the Fed talk about the need to
respond to foreign concerns and I think
that there is more coordination now
though obviously there is not an
agreement between the European Central
Bank and the Fed about what the world
needs the European Central Bank has not
been willing to cut rates the Fed has
been cutting rates drastically the Bank
of England has been somewhere in between
so that what you've got is is people who
really see the world and and what they
can do differently the the question of
investment opportunities you know if
investment opportunities are being
constrained by tight money and interest
rates go up that's one thing if you're
going to try to create investment
opportunities by lowering the price of
money you've got to change the hurdle
rate at which people are willing to to
put money in and that's difficult to do
at a time when the economy is going down
that's one of the reasons that my
feeling is that what the central bank
does in a slowdown is try to try to keep
the price of existing assets a little
higher by putting up more money but the
the real economy
is going to have to take care of return
of what Keynes called the animal high
spirits of business man you can't do
that with monetary policy demonstrated
that in the 30th yes I'd like to come
back to this rules versus discretion yes
as I mentioned earlier what do you think
is the interpretation the Fed has of its
amended to keep price stability
obviously it doesn't have any rules like
fixed
money growth rule or an inflation target
as other countries have some academics
however have thought that well there the
Fed may have a hidden rule I can tell
you the rule for example for these kind
of things I said may have a terrible if
the Taylor would know well I I think
that that that Greenspan and [ __ ] mean
that they've been been willing to
tolerate more a more inflation this last
year than one would have expected they
have certainly taken a very different
attitude me ECB I mean both Greenspan
and Larry Meyer and others are out there
saying there is no inflationary pressure
these these numbers that you see are
artifacts of other things because
they've been most concerned about the
slowdown the other country central banks
have a specific mandate to maintain the
value of the currency in its wisdom the
Congress has given the Fed a lot of
mandates it's supposed to maintain
employment it's supposed to maintain the
value of the currency it's it's it's
supposed to make sure that poor people
get access to credit it's supposed to do
a lot of things that the world's other
central banks don't have to do if
there's that there's a good book by Jay
by Melton I forgotten his first name now
called inside the Fed from about 15
years ago which looks at the targets
that the Fed is at various times looked
at mean the Fed targets the big things
it targets growth it targets inflation
and it targets unemployed
or employment but of course you can't do
that with monetary policy you must
choose a quote intermediate target close
close quote which presumably has some
direct sort of wheel and spokes
relationship with your big target at one
time in another the Fed has the Fed
through most of its existence has
targeted interest rates first place
that's what it can really do in the
Volcker years for a while
partly because of the immense
inflationary problem of the late
seventies and early eighties it targeted
monetary aggregates there's a little
colloquy between Greenspan and Volcker
that was overheard a few years ago
walking into a meeting when Volcker said
sort of casually whatever happened to m1
and Greenspan said it was a pretty good
rifle but you don't these things don't
work at this point in the game I mean if
I can write a check against the equity
value in my home what is the money
supply you get infinitely expand scible
velocity because it will turn up as as
velocity rather than a monetary
aggregate every once in a while
Greenspan says sort of wistfully but
maybe m2 was beginning to have an impact
again the amount of curve fitting that
had to be done to make M to look as
though it was a causative thing was just
to were great the answer to your
question is that Greenspan is himself a
hugely pride pragmatic person I you can
put it negatively by saying that he
steers the boat by its wake he studies
what has been happening and he makes
short-term extrapolate he's very very
good at it
whether that and and and for the period
that he has been chairman of the Fed
that has been a very good attitude
whether that is over time going to be
enough given the collapse of the models
I don't know but the Fed at present is
trying to do whatever it thinks works it
does it does it does not have rules and
it does not yet Greenspan also made it
talked the group of 30 in which he said
quite deadpan and these central bankers
and Big Shot bankers listening didn't
even laugh at all he said you know he
said we
the Fed spend more money on economic
analysis and on mathematics and on the
creation of economic models than anybody
else in the world and as a result we
have the best models and the best
forecasting models in the in the world
and the fact that these models have been
wrong for fourteen straight quarters
does not mean they will also be wrong in
the 15th you're stuck with that problem
you get magmatic I think we have a
couple of minutes more yes gentleman
back there you recounted a number of
instances where heads of state were
trying to influence central bank policy
now many countries in the world are now
creating central bank's which are
independent for the first time isn't
imitation the best form of flattery yeah
yes mine the the system that was created
in this country and the Federal Reserve
which rested upon central bank control
of the creation of bank liabilities
elsewhere in the world the basic control
was on the creation of bank assets in
this country we said we're gonna we're
going to limit the creation of bank
liabilities and we'll let the market
determine what these bank liabilities
are used for and for that purpose you
can have an independent central bank if
you're trying to to to give guidance
administrative guidance as the British
and the French in their different
languages handling Japanese called it
then you you you tell the banks where to
lend and where to create the assets we
went in the other direction and created
an independent central bank that would
influence creation of bank liabilities
we have now got to the point where it's
much more difficult to influence the
creation of liabilities because it's not
being done by the banks it's being done
elsewhere nevertheless this effort to
create a central bank that would be
independent of politicians is a great
example of course being New Zealand that
it must keep in mind that in New Zealand
there are no New Zealand
banks the but certainly the the notion
that the French government would give up
control and you know in this country
there was jawboning of the of the Fed
forever until Clinton and Rubin shut it
down when Volcker was invited by Reagan
it was invited by by by a Jimmy Carter
to become chairman of the Fed he went
down they didn't want the job much he
was being paid two-thirds again as much
as press on the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York and in many ways it's more
interesting job but he went down with a
list of things he wanted Jimmy Carter to
promise him of which the first one was
there will be no sniping from the White
House and no second-guessing by the kids
around the White House and and Carter
said yes but he didn't mean it
but Clinton thanks to Rubin and in large
part did mean it and Bush has clearly
decided to stay with that you know given
what the economy has done in the last
six months it's very hard to imagine an
administration prior to recent years
that would not have been jawboning the
Fed to move faster and do more and
indeed my own feeling is that Greenspan
moved in January when he did because
Bush was meeting with with the grandis
with the grand oofy Charlie the big
shots of US business and they were going
to call for lower interest rates so he
moved in midday before they could come
out in the afternoon and do it but but
certainly there has been remarkably
little sniping at Greenspan there has
been remarkably little insistence that
the Fed could do more and it may be that
we have entered into a time also where
this is considered a professional
responsibility rather than a political
football I wouldn't tell senator
sarbanes that because I think his
instincts still go back to were trying
to influence what the Fed does but
certainly it's not being done now
velocity like productivity is is is one
of these things that you put in at the
end because you got to make the equation
come out it's a it's a it's a it's
residual the transactional velocity of
money is just incredibly great we are
talking about trillions of dollars every
day that move through the New York
Clearing House and moved through Fedwire
and move through the foreign exchange
systems and and and now move through the
euro world where it's managed by a
private operation called sprint but the
income velocity of money is something
that you get later by looking at what
you say the gross domestic product was
which is not a very good number and what
you say the money supply was which is
not a very good number and that tells
you how often that money supply had to
turn over to make the I the identity
work of money times of a lot quantity
times velocity equals transactions noise
price which vehicle would offer them the
greatest efficiency in this velocity
equation would it be banks or investment
houses or insurance companies well the
the brokerage has is have have pioneered
multi-purpose accounts which have been
very efficient and useful for people
banks now offer them to but there's no
question that the cash management
account which Merrill Lynch pioneered in
the late 70s was a remarkable benefit
for consumers and you have to give
Merrill credit because the largest
single source of its income was three
customer balances the money that was
just left in the house when people sold
something before they bought something
else or when dividends were paid and
before they were sent out they didn't
pay interest on that and because that
would have been taking deposits which
they said was illegal and then suddenly
they moved to give up that income in
order to create this account which would
tie the customer to the brokerage house
rather than to his customers man and it
worked very very effectively my hunch is
that that sort of account is still
better done by the brokerage houses and
maybe some of the electronic guys like
Schwab then it is done by the
because banks tend to be slow-moving
okay thank you all very much